do you know what Thor had recently oh
God while we're on the topic of what we
think the future is going to be go on do
you think food has peaked
do you think do you think cooking
okay okay let me explain myself let me
explain it okay okay okay okay this is
this is gone going into like weirdo
shower thoughts mode this is like what
like British people thought when they
like discovered curry
spice fruits Peak guys yeah like do you
think you've tasted the best thing
you've you're ever going to taste in
your life already no uh I've gotten
close I'd say
what do you mean I got close for a video
uh I got served Sushi from the best
sushi chef in the world right um using
the best fish in the world and that one
piece of tuna that I had fatty yeah was
like the closest I've ever gotten to
coming in my pants while eating like
legitimately I I I think in terms of in
terms of food in general no I don't
think I've had the best thing in terms
of seafood yes I think I have had it
well I think maybe the ingredients well
it's always changing right because like
think about like uh you're gonna say
Russell Sprouts is that we're gonna say
yeah I mean I was gonna say brussels
sprouts you know they always find you
know I'm like remember when we like grew
up we like it was like a meme that you'd
never eat the Brussels sprouts
I [__] hated them and then suddenly
over like the past 10 years it almost
felt like people just figured out how to
cook them yeah like you know I think
genetically they've changed oh really
yeah right they're actually like even
genetic not as better anymore yeah I I
can't remember what could you call this
um I I think that something's changed
genetically and now they're a lot more
appetizing yeah and and obviously people
have gotten better at cooking them yeah
I think that goes hand in hand with like
when they taste better people get better
at cooking them because they want to use
them more yeah that's why like whenever
we're in the US and I see Brussels and
Sprouts of the menu I'm like we're
ordering these yeah I know they're going
to be bomb they're always so good if
they have the audacity to put it on a
menu oh you know every time every time
in Hawaii we ate them
yeah sure because like okay I don't know
I don't know if I've I don't I don't
know if this is just something like
worldwide or just something that I've
noticed in my very very small circles
but do you think people have just gotten
better at cooking periods yeah of course
because knowledge is more accessible and
we have tools in the kitchen that that
allow you to cook experiment more yeah
you know like rice rice cook is a great
way of getting perfect right people
discover how to properly cook rice
because of because because of Uncle
Roger I I don't think I'd ever had rice
that was cooked properly in my entire
life till I came to Japan really yeah
because I'll probably use [__]
sifting it through a column they're like
yeah I was taught to sift it yeah so
like that and then also you know just
technology getting better like
appliances getting better methods of
cooking getting like you know like we
have the air fryer now like stuff like
that I think they'll always be something
and then obviously we're always we're
always playing God and genetically
modifying our Foods yeah to make them
taste better so I think I think it'll
always get better and then we're
eventually going to get to that point
like in all the post-apocalyptic movies
where it's just like a one and all like
a one in all I mean I don't think we'll
ever get to that point because people
yeah I'm kind of doing that now I feel
like it's already there almost I drink
like there's meal replacements sometimes
when I'm streaming so I can't be
bothered to order food and I go I don't
know and it's so sad because I I'm kind
of like mourning the death of food yeah
you're like the one person who like
frogs over food I love food so much it's
so sad that I have to drink this thing I
don't have to but uh you're opting too
yeah because it's just easy food's great
though food's so great but I don't I
want to [__] I've seen him it's on my
grind yeah go on on stream just was like
hey guys I'm gonna be out be right back
in an hour I'm gonna go eat lunch
I just left his stream for an hour to go
eat lunch and I'm like mad respect to
you I don't know why I'm in my brain I
can't and don't want to do that and I'm
like I just want to keep doing the thing
yeah no because I mean I value getting a
lunch I I value enjoying my meal and
just having a me time uh I'm actually
just watching the news the dude's like
all right well there is more news uh but
I'm gonna head out for lunch I'll see
you guys now okay here's here's the
thing though okay um I mean I have the
privilege of doing this because because
streaming isn't my you know main job I
kind of see as a hobby but like if I'm
live I don't want to eat lunch and I
want to enjoy my lunch uh any other
office employee can be like all right
I'm going out for a lunch break what I
can't stream is do this you know it's
that's I I just went I just went on my
lunch break why is that why is that why
is that such a [__] like like awful
thought in the world of streaming you
know I think well I think it's because
like you know unlike at an office job
you don't have a bunch of people coming
to you like waiting to see what you're
doing you know that's like if you're out
of [__] football stadium and the
Umpire was like so I know we're in the
middle of a game uh 30 000 people in the
stadium but uh I really need to go get a
snack so I'm gonna hold the game right
now the games actually I was like the
game's like going for eight hours maybe
maybe some sports okay but you don't
stream five days a week you know [__]
there are some little joys in life that
I that I think people all people should
have and a lunch break and a nice dinner
is just one of those things you know I
just would have loved him in a viewing
their stream like [__] enjoying every
moment of it yeah what was Chad doing
the entire time and you're like all
right I'm going out no because I've I've
literally been on the stream and I'm
like sure I forgot I had a meeting now
uh I'll be back in an hour and I'll just
put it on like be right back
okay I've done that yeah I've done that
that's funny I don't know I'm just like
if you know streamers are so it it
always seems like they're just addicted
to streaming and I'm like a part of it
it's just having kind of have to be yeah
part of it yeah I mean it's not that I'm
addicted it's that I want to provide the
best viewer experience and me not
disappearing for an hour as part of that
yeah
yeah an important thing is having a
healthy lifestyle around that and I'm
like which is like level impossible for
a lot of streams and also I just don't
really care so I I do this as a hobby so
I'm like if I want my lunch break I'm
out I'm I'm jealous I respected I wish I
had that mindset you should try it once
yeah you should be like what the [__]
just to see how they respond yeah but uh
I guess I guess like well what are we
talking about yeah the thing is about
food I was just like there's been a few
moments in my life where you remember
that first time you've tried this new
dish that has not reached any flavor
profile that you've like had previously
yeah and it's just like you know I
remember like the first time I had like
A5 wagyu and first time obviously it was
like holy [__] this is Godlike
um I've never tasted like this that's
all I don't have something to compare
this to my previous experience because
nothing has tasted like this thing I'm
tasting and I'm like have I have I is is
am I ever going to experience that again
you know it's have have I tasted
everything that there is possibly to
taste that's going to taste good you
know because you know I'm sure there's
things I haven't tasted well unless
you've traveled to every single country
in the world with every single different
food culture in the world I don't think
you'll ever get to that point to be
honest you know like not everything
you're going to have is gonna be the
most like orgasm-inducing thing like A5
wagyu but like you're probably gonna you
know if you travel the world and you see
all sorts of different food cultures
there's probably gonna be one item in
the hundreds of thousands where you're
like holy [__] why is no one talking
about this yeah it's just I realize
Japan like spoiled me because when I
moved to Japan that was just one year of
just like every month I'm like holy [__]
this is amazing holy [__] fatty tuna all
right A5 wagyu unagi uh
oh my God that was that was such a
magical year and I'm like chasing that
high again I'm just chasing that high
it's never gonna happen enjoy what you
have enjoy what you have I love what you
love it I'm not saying I don't I don't
like good food anymore it's just I think
Japan has just ruined your perception of
the peak of food yeah
I'm like I'm like now nowadays I'm like
maybe food's Peaks yeah I don't know I
don't know I don't know maybe I've
piqued my food experience I'm never
gonna relive a year ago this food peaked
well that's that's the thing that's the
thing where I can you know you know
we've been to you know I'm sure Merlin
has taken us to some like Michelin stuff
like a restaurant and to me it's never
lived up to the price point oh it's
never even come close to being like the
best thing I've tasted and that's true
for like most Michelin star places uh
the thing I hate most about Michelin
star places and it's always the fancy
places that do this single worst dishes
in the food existence is just foam
there's just an obsession with foam in
like rich places like meringue and [__]
no no like just foam they'll be like
we've turned this fish into a foam and
uh it's delightful and you try it you're
like it tastes like a fish calmed in my
mouth I'm like I don't want this like
you have had this we've been to
restaurants where where which one um
that has some Blumenthal one no not that
one um there's just in Japan they do it
a lot I went to one the other day and
they had like unagi foam and I thought
[__] hell the [__] yeah I was like
this tastes like ass I don't want this
and then I went to it when we went to
that Sukiyaki place oh yeah there's one
where baleen took us too and it was like
it was an egg it was egg foam you would
dunk it in and it was gross because it
tastes like again it was like foam it's
like I hate foam stop foaming [__] just
give me a liquid or a solid God damn it
yeah so that's my random phone yeah so
to me I hate the word deconstructed
where
if there is something Deconstructed on
the menu I already know I'd rather just
have the thing that is deconstructing
it's a Lunchable deconstruction
that's basically what deconstructed is
we're taking a plastic wrap it's just
very fancy Lunchables that's what that's
what you've done here isn't Mr chair
like fajitas deconstructed tacos kind of
Runners uh kinda I mean
it's just a hamburger [__]
wait hold on hold on hold on hold on let
him cook
yeah I don't know I I like features
though fajitas it is great yeah
I like it because of the control you
know the control of how you can make the
fajita the way you want to make your
fajita you know I mean the weakness of
fajita is that you you are the one
making it though too because you're like
you're like you've had three fajitas in
you're like this is great and then
you're like wait
I have two tortillas left and way too
much meat and vegetables the other way
around that's not your problem that's
the portion size problem you know you'd
never get this problem in America
because you'd you'd have or sometimes
you you share with someone and they put
way too much in their fajita you're like
you've got to calm down we are sharing
this so that's the problem you put two
worth of fajitas in one yeah you've got
to stop that right now because we I am
not rationing this no but that's the
problem with fajitas right like you said
you like the control of it right but
it's like it's you're not in control
because the
portion sizes that they give you are
already like preset well unless you're
not actually in control you're just like
you're in a you're in a pre-rendered cut
scene
and that shit's spilling out everywhere
I'm like you're doing it wrong you're
doing it wrong yeah I've just realized
why is this just like a scientific fact
when you order a fajita you will always
get less like you would always get less
Meats than there is
but like fajita Patties or like because
it's cheaper for them
they're cutting the corners bro